alors on a widom d link est avec nous
vous êtes ancien skinheads néonazis
devenu donc moines bouddhistes je vais
dire c'est un peu
alors oui à vous avez une histoire
devient parcours fou puisque vous avez
vous avez même un aigle nazi tatoué sur
la poitrine
ouais en fait j'étais en recherche
d'identité et puis un moment de ma vie
quand j'avais 15 ans j'ai vu un opuscule
skinheads ça m'a attiré mais et puis
c'était vraiment des fous furieux donc
pour entrer dans un groupe comme ça bah
il a fallu que je me fasse un véritable
lavage de cerveau est comme quand vous
dites des fous furieux c'est à dire que
c'est il se passer quoi bas des gens
vraiment qui frappe qui sont
indisciplinés voir des gens malades que
vous vous êtes rentré la dent puisque
vous étiez la recherche entre guillemets
d'une famille en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que comme j'ai vécu dans une cité
si tu veux battu grandi trop vite
il ya trop de personnes qui veulent du
mal et c'est donc tu cherches
voilà des personnes qui peuvent te
protéger te donner de la force de donner
une identité quoi et puis bah quand tu
te retrouves dans un groupe comme ça
découpe et de la société
et puis tu arrives à un moment avec une
telle haine que je moi je me rappelle ça
m'arrivait de sauter à pieds joints sur
la tête de deux personnes jeu ont
massacré des gens toute la journée
c'était un plaisir vraiment c'était
sadique et puis cette violence en fait
cette haine
on la comprend pas vraiment on vit avec
des gens et puis on accepte une
idéologie de plus en plus au point de se
faire tatouer en fait de 1 aigle nazi
etc
c'est une escalade en fait mais c'est
une escalade mais deux je dirais que
c'est même pas une compréhension
politique ou sociale ou quoi que ce soit
c'est de la haine pure c'est de la haine
en fait maintenant que je suis moins
depuis 30 ans a alors depuis trois ans
va être mois entend donc quitté d'un
état comme ça à un état de paix il faut
en verser des larmes ça a été difficile
un métier malheureux malheureux en fait
tu sais le malheur le bonheur c'est
quelque chose de difficile à comprendre
quand j'étais un skinhead mon bonheur
c'était de faire de mal
aux gens maintenant mon bonheur c'est de
faire du bien qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi il ya eu 7
ce changement bas ce qui s'est passé
c'est que tu peux pas me battre contre
le bien qui à l'intérieur de toi même à
un moment si tu veux je me suis retrouvé
complètement déconnecté de cette
coquille
alors j'avais une réputation vraiment
les gens craignaient tout quand j'étais
à acheter un craignos à cette époque là
les jours ils le savent mais à un moment
si tu veux je pouvais me regarder et je
le dis mais qu'est ce que je suis l'un
des juges était avec des montres autour
de moi il ya eu un événement particulier
à des événements où il y en a eu en
particulièrement
j'ai donc j'habitais dans un hlm est en
face de moi il y avait une famille david
g ou habitions à bagnols avait une
famille juive que je connaissais depuis
tout petit et un jour je sors habillé
comme un néo nazi tout en noir
railpower j'avais une insignes nazis
tatoué sur la tête et je sors de du
palier il ya une jeune fille juive que
je connais depuis tout petits qui sort
avec son bébé
et là je ressens un truc pas possible
c'est du lourd
maman et mais j'assume pas et je dis bon
salut tu vas bien qu'elle y toi mdi
salut williams toi et puis on se dirige
vers l'ascenseur et puis là et je sens
vraiment quelque chose qui me prend les
camps de concentration je commence à
réaliser ce qui se passe je prends
l'ascension avec c'était quelque chose
d'insupportable quelque part mais je
voulais pas je voulais pas céder
quelques uns
et puis graduellement bas tous ces
événements bah un moment ma je pouvais
plus le supporter quoi j'ai dégueuler la
violence mais le point c'est que pour
changer ça pas été facile parce qu'il y
avait une telle violence en moi et que
j'essayais véritablement de la dominer
mais parfois quand elle ressortait c'est
comme s'il y avait 10 personnes en moins
c'était ma puissance elle était décuplée
et ça me rendait tellement malheureux et
donc le la chance que j'ai eue ce qu'est
un membre du gang demong en fait il a
pris une balle en
il est devenu handicapé et donc ça m'a
vraiment porté vers la compassion
j'avais plus de sentiment en moi et
quand mon pote il est tombé comme ça il
y en a eu qui a pris une balle dans la
tête quoi et l'autre est devenue
handicapée bassam a fait roseaux
ressortir des sentiments et à partir de
là la chance que j'ai eue c'est que lui
l'a changé il a été vers une vie
spirituelle et comme c'était mon ami que
je m'étais occupé le même et tu es débat
je les ai suivis et après ça m'a ouvert
les portes à l'amour quoi à la bae et ça
a été incomplètement un chamboulement et
mes bois un gros travail parce que
c'était dur quoi je me suis retrouvé
dans des monastères par exemple ou quand
quelqu'un me faisais une réflexion bah
quand vous vous avez vécu comme ça un
tel degré de violence vous savez que
vous mettez un coup de tête ceci cela
vous lyncher une personne et c'était des
flashs comme ça de violence qui venait
me chercher et j'ai beaucoup pleuré j'ai
beaucoup prié en fait pour pour vraiment
changer quoi et cette bataille à
l'intérieur elle m'a fait voir
véritablement c'est qu'avant j'étais
faible en fait j'étais faible donner un
coup vouloir du mal pensée du mal à
accepter des dj des idéologies comme
celle là c'est de la faiblesse et j'ai
réalisé qu'en fait que cette faiblesse
elle était en moi le monstre il est en
moi et la vie spirituelle ça m'a permis
de me battre à l'intérieur
maintenant je peux tolérer je peux
pardonner je peux aimer même chargement
ou sentais bien maintenant un
complètement mais jamais dit beaucoup
par jour je médite six heures sept
heures par jour mais vous avez vraiment
l'air c'est d'enterrer que vous avez
mangé doc gynéco il est vraiment il est
tranquille
gilles verdez le témoignage effrayant un
moment incroyable de télévision joue dix
en dix ans c'est incroyable et et ce
parcours que vous avez fait qui est
profond et et qu'on sent vraiment très
intense
le risque pour revenir à l' enquête de
mediapart c'est que d'autres néo nazis
n'accomplissent pas ce parcours et
qu'ils soient faibles et qu' ils soient
recrutés par des militaires actrice et
là ça peut péter dans ces cas là
monsieur nécessaire la cre avait cessé
voilà c'est ce qu'on a essayé au procès
mais juste là faudrait qu'on s'arrête
deux minutes sur sur ceux de ce
témoignage
qui qu'il faut vous avez vous avez peur
de tuer quelqu'un monde
bah en fait j'ai été plusieurs fois
arrêté par la police judiciaire pour les
affaires de meurtres et je suis pas
tombé quoi parce que en fait danser dans
ces guerres de gangs
on a affaire à des groupes on sait pas
ce qu'on fait on frappe des gens le
laissent mais vous vous étiez vous étiez
fondamentalement raciste ou pas du tout
le monde ses mythes racistes n'ont pas
fait le point c'est que je vais vous
dire je suis pour moi c'est comme une
autre vie quoi donc chez même plus que
j'étais tellement que c'était
dégueulasse
vous étiez enrôler en fait comme dans
une secte c'est pire que ça c'est pire
que ça que même spirituellement
j'ai connu des des groupes sectaires
j'ai eu des expériences
1 parce que dans la religion celle mais
c'est la même veine mais d'une manière
différente
non c'est c'est vraiment c'est
particulier alors je voudrais faire le
point et ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai fondé une
association à et michel non violence ou
ged justement les anciens néonazis assez
sarine aides etc et je les aide à sortir
de cette violence est ce que je voulais
vous poser quand c'est essayer d'en
sortir
ah ouais et puis ça marche il ya
beaucoup de gens qui me contactent
profil qui vient vous voir quel style de
profilés il ya de tout des gens qui
sortent de 20 ans de prison pour meurtre
comme des jeunes cons 14 ans de toutes
sortes de personnes et simplement rien
quand par exemple quand je passe une
fois à la télé ça leur fait un déclic et
il me recontacte par exemple deux ans ou
si l'on a ou six mois après ça a changé
ma vie justin phrase grâce à toi j'ai
arrêté j'ai pu de n y en a qui
deviennent même antiraciste tout ce à
quoi ces gens